this day and age i think is not always
the steamier creative they always come
out the best idea some of the young
talent a lot more daring they have no
baggage they will astonish actually some
other than us thinking and especially in
the in the digital world right now so
are they it's important to just just
give them a open platform and open
environment to do that first I think
it's important to identify the insight
and the news then from there we kind of
need to understand our own product and
brand s wrong because we need to be
truthful about what we are trying to
communicate and then from there we will
develop the creative idea we will also
develop the engagement plan around the
creative idea so that we can really
communicate clearly to the consumers
some of the more successful campaigns
that we've been working on one of them
is the ID leaders Olympic campaign was a
huge campaign took us a year and a half
to finish we wanted to create a movement
and what better way to support the
nation when 1.3 billion people come
together to give support to the athlete
and then the Utley will feel that the
entire nations behind him with the
samsonite heaven and hell at the whole
idea came about when we were at the
airport and looking at the luggage and
all that and you get very disappointed
when the luggage comes on the conveyor
belt and or broken up whether you're in
the economy class business class or
first class so realize that weather
whatever classroom travel I mean it's
always heavenly up there but your
baggage goes through the same kind of
hellish treatment so I mean that the at
biscuit was inspired in the airport
another my favorite project is the
sensory campaign for the China
environmental protection foundation we
actually go into a piece of a century
landscape but in close observation
realized that this landscape is actually
made up of other industrial pollution or
the automated pollution this campaign
actually brought a lot of profile for
the China environmental protection
foundation
besides all this interesting projects
that i work on I think really at this
stage the most interesting project for
me is to grow and nurture the creative
Department we create a environment that
hopefully a lot more stimulating by
first showing them what we think is good
communication and good advertising and
then we also have a very open
environment where young talents can come
in and show us why they can do as well
we have a very flat structure it's
always the Talon and the passion that
wins at the end of the day when the team
comes together and when someone has
something interesting to say and share
it's not always the most senior person
who's got the n say so I think that that
always encouraged the younger talent and
office to be a lot more open and share
the opinion and ideas this definitely
helps with the timber because once I
rocky get in the way and you know ego
get in the way it's always is not always
the best idea that means I think the
most valuable lesson I learned is not to
be arrogant so I think it's just to be
humble continue to be hungry and create
the best work and I think that's where
the respect will come from
you